[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday it's been a year since we
plunged into the covet 19 pandemic
an ordeal none of us was ready for
during that time we've sought the advice
and expertise
of the brilliant cbs news medical
contributor dr david agus to help us
make sense of what we hope
is a once in a lifetime experience
federal health workers are screening
passengers arriving at three u.s
airports this weekend the deadly
coronavirus is spreading beyond mainland
china where it has now claimed more than
40 lives
quarantines work we are going to have
quarantines in the united states of
america
it's not if but it's when and where you
call this the new normal
this is the new normal we gonna have a
different way i mean you know we're no
longer gonna go like this
anymore we're gonna go like this we're
not gonna be shaking hands
on friday president trump declared a
national emergency
new york and california illinois are in
lockdown mode
where do we stand now in this idea that
so many people
want to be able to get tested if they
feel the need is there
we're not close in the testing
infrastructure in this country
unfortunately
at major centers there are long long
lines this is a war
and we're missing the supplies we need
in this war the united states has
crossed a grim milestone with more than
a hundred thousand confirmed cases
what should people know about covering
their faces in public
this is something that's imperative we
all have to play our part
how do we determine when the right time
is to ease those stay-at-home orders
we'll be graded right we'll go out with
masks at first it's not going to happen
all at once on a personal note the only
way i know how to ask this is it's been
six weeks
since i've been with my husband and my
stepson and i want to know when someone
like me is going to be able to get
tested
so that i can do that unfortunately
presently in certain areas of the
country and i say that certain areas
have testing
and they're very efficient at it other
areas are just overwhelmed
it could be two more years before we
have this herd immunity
how do we get there well it's a one word
answer i mean a very very simple word
vaccine
vaccine vaccine vaccine the first major
challenge for social distancing
regulations as americans venture out for
memorial day
weekend more than three months since the
first wave struck mostly cities in the
north and east and then declined
big increases are now being reported
across the sun belt
much of the country is moving backwards
the key is
behavior if people are wearing a mask in
social distancing cases will go down
if they're not they won't the president
was in a maryland hospital after being
diagnosed with coronavirus
the first thing they did was they gave
him an experimental drug
a cocktail and then yesterday evening he
started a daily course of rendissevere
as we approach the holidays the
coronavirus rate appears to be
increasing tens of millions of families
around the country
are thinking about this and talking
about this what should they do it is a
major issue
thanksgiving this year is not going to
be like other years
the u.s now leads the world with more
than 13 million
infections cases are up hospitalizations
are up everything continues to rise is
there any reason to think
that that will change every single
holiday we've had there's been a
significant increase
and so i am worried about the next six
to eight weeks i
really am breaking news in the fight
against the coronavirus
the federal government approving the
nation's first covit 19 vaccination
this is it right i mean finally there is
light at the end of the tunnel we're
going to go on offense against this
virus
new daily case count down 64 from that
all-time high
why are we seeing this drop now because
over the holidays we let our guard down
and we got together and that dramatic
increase happened over the first several
weeks of january
now it's going down because of several
reasons we're more compliant we're
wearing masks which is the good thing
vaccinations went from 19 million to
60 million now president biden
suggesting we'll have enough supply for
all americans by
august so are we on track for that yeah
i think by the end of the summer we
could have
heard immunity in the country it's
possible but we have to execute
wow dr agus joins us now uh doc looking
back on the events of the past year
which
i felt like 10 years for many what were
our successes
what were our failures
well i think our success clearly is the
vaccine we developed a vaccine in record
time and it's being manufactured
and by may we're going to have it for
all people in this country
the big failures i think are we
politicized science
and medicine we had a delay in testing
by
several months and that and we never had
a testing system that was implemented
efficiently across the country
and that was a big problem and then the
masks i mean the science you know one
day we would say one thing and one day
another the first time ever
the world saw the sausage being made in
our field
and then they didn't trust it wow that
that is saying it
but i have to tell you dr agus you were
one of the first
to call the quarantines i remember this
specifically
so moving forward what are the biggest
challenges
facing us right now
well we have to get to where we can roll
out the vaccines and so people are now
letting down their guard
we're seeing numbers in certain areas of
the country tick up and certainly that
worries me
we have to keep wearing the masks and
doing the right things
to get to those vaccines and then we're
going to have to really build the
program
for a regular update of the vaccine
which is the boosters
this is going to be a new normal and we
have to accept that and we have to stop
politicizing that and we have to stop
arguing over things that are on social
media and really talk data
and science dr aegis where do you see us
one year from now
one year from now i see us having a
regular booster to covet 19 or related
viruses
i see us back in the workplace most
people people who work from home will
i see us more like asian countries where
when you're ill
you wear a mask or you stay home before
it was kind of heroic i have a cold i'm
going to go to work to show how tough a
worker i am
and you would spread things we're going
to have a new normal
unless we care about others doc we've
only aged one year but your zoom has
gotten
significantly better than that in the
past year
i don't mean to joke it's not funny but
you've
uh doctor you've been so fantastic over
the past years michelle noted you you
did call
it uh so early and we appreciate your
time as always
thank you it's an amazing team to work
with at cbs this morning saturday and i
thank all of you
together we're hopefully educating
people all right buddy
talk to you soon doctor